le lait qui provient de cette vache
coûte maintenant plus cher ça va combler
les déficit là encore dans notre
entreprise avoir une ferme comme celle
d'Yves Lamy iamachiche coûte de plus en
plus cher aussi transport du lait diesel
pour opérer et alimentation des vaches
tout a augmenté dans les derniers mois
on peut pas absorber toute cette dépense
supplémentaire là carrément pas le il
faut réajuster le prix sinon on voyait
passer le premier février le prix du
lait à la ferme a augmenté de 2,2 %.
cette hausse étant de ça de celle de
septembre et février 2022 je suis
content de la hausse que j'ai ancien
aussi que les consommateurs
ont de la difficulté de la difficulté à
suivre un peu plus loin dans la chaîne
cette hausse fait mal les fabricants de
produits laitiers de la petite laiterie
aux grands industriels doivent payer
plus pour la même quantité de lait qu'il
mettront en
[Musique]